From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
I have this little work on here.
I think we'll do good.
Today is Friday, the 23rd of September 2011.
My name is Joe Mosnier of the Southern Oral History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I am in Amherst, Massachusetts on the campus of the University of Massachusetts in New Africa House with John Bishop, our project videographer,
to do an oral history for the Civil Rights History Project, which is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
We are privileged today to be with Dr. William Lamar Strickland, who has taught here for many years and long before that, deep engagement in the movement and the whole host of capacities that we'll discuss today.
Dr. Strickland, it's a pleasure.
Bill, Bill.
Just a quick note before we dive into the interview, our videographer John Bishop was long personal acquaintance with Worth W. Long and before we turned on, we were chatting a little bit about a mention of Worth.
I thought maybe we just asked you to lay that down here so we don't miss it.
I assume people know Worth was regarded as the poet of Snick and for some strange reason there's a quote that's been attributed to Stokely, which actually was Worth's quote.
And it was quote, false face to America, we have found you out.
That's also a work.
Bill, let me have you begin today with just recalling your family and your parents and how you just come up in Oxford and how you foundry kind of out of that context, say to Boston one?
Wow.
Well, it was elementary school, I had a teacher who thought I should apply to Latin school and Latin school had a procedure where they would let you in based on your grades.
And then as you sat in the auditorium, they would tell you look to your left and look to your right because he, because at the time Latin school was all boys, of course, 16, 35, they're not going to be here at the end.
So you enter in class six, which is the seventh grade because we had six years of Latin and that was correct.
Almost 700 guys started out and we graduated about 22230 of whom six of us were black.
What if you were to some recollections of your parents?
Well, my father was killed in the war and my mother was worked for Raytheon, she worked for Union for Raytheons.
But I had this, I had aunts in Roxbury and fabulous aunts in Newark, New Jersey and my mother's family was from Georgia.
So I was as a child, I would go to visit them in Georgia.
In fact, it, a little town, a little town outside of Macon called, called, haddock, Macon.
And I later, I later found out, I guess it was my great grandmother was the offspring of a plantation owner.
And the, because the town between Macon and haddock was a town called Gray.
And this plantation owner was evidently a major figure in Georgia during the Confederacy Madison Gray.
And my uncle, my uncle was named after him, Gray.
But evidently this was a fairly, I guess, open mind because he left part of his land to my mother's family.
So that was the land that they had when I went, when I went as a child to visit them in Georgia.
Which branch of service? Marine Corps.
Oh, no, he was, I mean, I was in the Marine Corps.
He was killed well.
Oh, God.
I think in the Italian, in the Italian campaign.
You've written in certain places about, kind of, part of the family and community world, grew up in Roxbury, and included, I'm a student, through, I think, Malcolm Little.
Yes, I just recently wrote about that, tried to, to, we could pitchulate that because there's been a recent biography of Malcolm X X, to which I take great exception.
And I wanted to establish that my recollections came from personal experience and not from second-hand experience.
Because I met Malcolm X when I was very young, because he was a very good friend of my cousin, whom I say in the article, was my hero, because I would be at my aunt and uncle's house and girls would call him from New York.
And I thought that was the coolest thing. It was the coolest, coolest thing.
So I wanted to grow up and be exactly like him, the, but they also were part of a group which I, on, on later reflection, I think, may have been,
significantly West Indian, because my cousin was, his father was, was, was, was, was, was, was, Barbadian.
The uncle Jake, that, that was his name, Jake Edmund, and it's, and my relatives claim that at some point in my youth, I said that, that, the uncle Jake, I called uncle Jake, the man too mean to die.
But he was, but he was cool. And, and he was also a numbers banker.
And so I grew up with numbers sheets and all around my, and uncle's house. But Leslie got out of the war and he came, he got into a, I don't know what the cause of it was.
And so he got into a hassle down at Tremont Street, in fact, I really think it's the same pool room where, where Malcolm X met, met Shorty Jarvis.
And so he came home and, and got his pistol and went back and whacked one or more of the people.
But because my uncle was in touch with the Irish mafia, he got, Leslie the best criminal defense attorney.
So Leslie only got a year and a day eventually. So he was in Charlestown State Prison at the same time as Malcolm X.
So when I met Malcolm X later, when Malcolm X came to speak at Harvard, I went, talked, went up after his, after his talk, mentioned Roxbury and, and Leslie.
And then we were tight until he died.
Yeah, it's a little bit more about, um, the personal history in those years. Um, obviously it was something up a, an usual quite unusual thing still for American, American man to be up through Boston, and in the library.
I'm interested in your recollections of moving through those experiences.
Well, there may or may not have been a quota, but there were only 11 of us, out of 1000 guys at Harvard.
And because of that number, you knew all the black guys who had gone to Harvard 10 years before you were 20 years before you were in 20 years after you.
So it was, um, an inform. And then they would, you know, they, they was a little socialization process when you arrived.
They would say, well, most of the people whom you will account to here will believe that you're only here for one of two reasons.
That you are some made son or that you are a genius in your responsibility is to demonstrate point B.
So there was a nurturing, um, group presence in, in, in Cambridge, in Cambridge was.
And, and I remember, you know, Harvard, I have very, very fond memories of, of Harvard, Harvard taught, you know, like Dubois, you know, Dubois started writing for newspapers when he was in, uh,
a high school student at Great Barrington. And he, when he got to Harvard, he flunked.
I think it was English one. It was introduced because he's to have a compulsory freshman writing class for everyone.
And I had been similarly favored in my skipped kindergarten and they wanted me to skip first grade and then done well at Latin school.
And the, so when I got into the writing class, I was a little floored with my language.
And, uh, we had a English teacher, even Mr. Russo, who said to us, and now young man, I am going to teach you the secret of good writing.
The secret of good writing is rewriting. And so I was able to carry that on, to carry that to, uh, to, uh, on to Harvard.
But it was, I have very pleasant memories of Cambridge. Yeah.
Except when they asked me to put, leave them on my money, leave them on my money in my will.
Little money that I have.
I had meant to ask earlier. I just want to make sure I'm, I bet it's here. Yeah, your birthday is the fourth of January, nineteen, thirty-seven.
So you, and you finished a Boston Latin in...
Fifty-four.
Fifty-four. Oh, so basically with Brown.
What's the name of the Brown? Yeah, I wasn't thinking about Brown, does I?
Actually, that's not quite true because I was, let me think about that, because I was involved with the NAACP Youth Council when I was in high school.
And they had, uh, a slogan, you know, Free by '63" (NAACP youth slogan) + Emancipation Proclamation centennial.
You know, the, Free by '63" (NAACP youth slogan) + Emancipation Proclamation centennial. So the, uh, I forgot, Jesus.
I had forgotten that I was involved with NAACP Youth Council.
Well, on that point, you kind of anticipated that, but it was going to be my next question, which is, were you, uh,
did you come from a race family and were you a young, were you an adolescent with much of that question from your mom?
No, particularly. It's, um...
There were, um...
episodes. I didn't think about them at the time, and they crystal, the significance of them crystallized later,
and they were going to visit my, you know, well, as I said, my, my, my uncle Gray, who was another role model of mine.
He had to leave Georgia because he, uh, he had a girlfriend who, our, our Alzheimer was being, you know, quite, quite striking.
And some white guy was pursuing her, and I don't know whether he killed him, but they had a confrontation. He at least beat the hell out of him.
And then he had to leave. He went to Detroit to live with his older brother, my uncle, in, in, in, in Detroit.
But later on, I mean, when I got to Harvard, as I mentioned in, in the, in the Malcolm X article, and was in this graduate,
it let me into this graduate seminar with C. Eric Lincoln, and, uh...
and, and with, and with, and with me young, and I had...
I started going to, uh, as I said, in the article, race was all around me, and I started, and, and, and, running to Malcolm X again.
And I started going to, what was then, Temple No. 11, which, which, Farrakhan, who was then known as, as Louis X.
And listening, as I also say, in my notes to you, that I was very attracted to the, to Malcolm X's world view.
But I, um...
And so I started thinking about, going to Georgia, and you come out of, you come out of, the train station, and, and etched in stone, and, and the building, and, and the color, and white.
And also I, I had been, I had been in, in the chorus, as well. And I remember, and this is all, you said you'd interviewed, uh, the, the charades.
And the, I remember, being called into, they asked, for my next duty station, and they asked me, how would I like to go to Albany?
And the only Albany, I knew it was Albany in New York. So I said, I thought to myself, oh, that's super. I can swoop down the Harlem, it, it, it, it, it, it, it, catcher, uh, and then I went down to, to Howard, because there was,
one of our rival fraternities, the capis had a, a big social event called the Capiton dance. So, and I had almost gone to Howard, um,
because I had been offered a super scholarship, and they had brought me down to Howard, and I walked across campus, and saw a million girls who looked like Hallibary.
And, um, I had a, a neighborhood friend, Carl McCall, who was, treasure, Lieutenant Governor of New York, at some point.
And he had gone to Dartmouth, and he was there with, with, a, a guy, whose name will come to me, perhaps, who was a little older, whose mother was the principal of the famous, I think she was the, or he, or he had gone as an undergraduate to Dunbar High School, the famous black school in Washington.
And, and this guy was a basketball player, and he had, he had left Dartmouth, gone to Howard, and then we, and then we turned to, uh, to Dartmouth.
So, I was talking to my mother and friends about going to Howard, and then, and then going up to Cambridge, and they said in effect, uh, schmuck, take you behind the Cambridge.
So, the, uh, the, because back in those days, you were, there was a community, so it wasn't just you and your family, your church, you know, you know, about your exploits, and, uh, your, and your accomplishments.
So, you had, in essence, you had the responsibility of the race, because we were told, we had to be twice as good as white people, white competitors.
So, you had that, that responsibility. But I must say that if you, if you grow up in, well, if you, if you remember the, the famous movie 10, or if you grew up in a, in a community where,
you, you believe that the, the women you encounter, or eight, nine, and ten, then you go to Howard and see, that they're really only fours and fives.
You know, uh, socially, you said, woof, have mercy Jesus.
So, with, I said, now you've gone, you've gone to Harvard, and Howard, Howard can wait, and so it didn't wait.
But then, depending on the other stories, just that when I looked at my, while I was at Howard and looked at my orders, I saw that it wasn't Albany, New York, but Albany, Georgia, or as the natives pronounced it all banny.
And that was another, the Marine Corps was a very important formative experience, because most of the people, the military, I assume still, fundamentally a Southern institution, and the people that you had in the Corps were, especially the opera.
Especially the opera, at all, worse, um, with Southerners, and the enlisted men were Southerners, and, or young guys, whom the judge had told, we have two choices, the joint, or the Marine Corps, but it was, but I learned about, um, dimensions of white America that never would have learned otherwise, and I'd not been in the Corps.
When were you in America?
56, 59.
What were some of those, what were the examples of some of those things, you know?
Well, the Marine Corps had, uh, a culture, and that you, they instilled in you, I don't know what they're doing now, because now all the uniforms look alike, and, uh, the whole period of, of training is not the same as it used to be.
But they, if you make a distinction between who you are or were as a civilian, and then as a, a jarhead, there are things that you do when you're a civilian that are civilized.
If it's raining or snowing, you go inside.
The, um, and what they teach you is when you think, that you cannot take another step, you can run five more miles.
So you become acquainted with reserves, personal reserves that you would never otherwise have known, and that creates a certain, um, image, identity, which also can work against you.
Because people didn't think they're, you know, they're, uh, invulnerable.
Um, but it does, I mean, they, you develop a kind of superior already, attitude towards civilians, and to the army, and the Navy, the swabbies, because the army shoots from the 300-yard line, we shoot from the the 300-yard line.
So they instilled, they, for some of these guys, the core was their mother and their daddy.
I mean, I don't know, I don't know some of their personal stories, but for some of these guys, the Marine Corps was everything for them.
And that, and trying to understand, um, where those needs came from, was educational.
And then they also, you become more, you become more humble, because I remember being in boot camp, and the, uh, in Parris Island + the Camp + then "Le Jeune", and then the camp, and then later on in Parris Island + the Camp + then "Le Jeune", that, um, I'm walking across.
The base and find myself humming the Everly Brothers.
That, and get indoctrinated in an, in an, in an atmosphere, because I had, you know, been going to story, building the stables, and, and was deep, and was deep into jazz, um, and our, and our, and our, and our, and our, and our, and B.
But, when you enveloped in an environment, it's, it's interesting how it can have, it can creep into your consciousness.
I'm walking around, the base humming, Everly Brothers.
And, and I'm still in touch with one of my old buddies, all of the way, when we weren't in the same outfit, just came up to visit me from, well, there was a big event in DC for the Buffalo Soldiers.
He's living in Savannah, where they just murdered, uh, outside of Jackson (Georgia), where they just murdered Troy, Troy Anthony Davis, and he wrote his bike up.
He was also, um, he came up, he must have sell his house and bought some, and then he, and then he wrote up, up here to Amherst, to, you know, to visit me.
So there is this, there is a fraternity at the States with you forever, actually.
So, coming up, Rincord, you went into, I went back to, I went back to Harvard.
Yeah, and you already enrolled there, briefly.
Yeah, so, um, I'm interested to moving through the last half of the, of the 50s, things like, things like, huge things like, brown and muckum ray and, and a till and,
little rock and all.
I'm just wondering about how you're watching those things unfold and thinking about them at the time.
As you have best you can conjure your call?
I wasn't thinking much about the thing that I, that I think struck the consciousness of everyone.
And, subjectly, was the reason I've later discovered why many people of my generation joined SNCC, was the murder of Emmett Till,
because Jet had his picture displayed.
Um, and then at Harvard, I took an English course,
was a very famous literary, professor of literature at the time, Howard Mumford Jones.
And he had us reading Richard Wright, Uncle Tom's Children.
Uncle Tom's Children were below your mind.
And people still, I talked to my friends, colleagues in literature about the significance of that book,
because to me, I mean, I teach it in my, when I teach, um, civil rights on my Malcolm X Martin course,
I start the, the students off with Uncle Tom's Children.
I want them to understand just how capricious racism, Southern racism was,
and how the least little thing could suddenly become a matter of life and death.
So I read Uncle Tom's Children, that helped, and then James Baldwin, Notes of a Native Son, he has an essay,
which in SNCC says, has ever been a Negro at some point is not consumed with rage and wants to.
And I said, oh, I'm not the only one.
So, and then it's, I was at Harvard, and that's when I, um, joined Northern Student Movement, Northern Student Movement was, as I mentioned,
was started by, um, when young whites undergraduate at, at, at Yale P.D.
a countryman, and it had city projects all around the country in Chicago and Detroit, and Boston, Hartford, New York.
Um, and they had somehow connected to NAD, because that's how I first met Stokely.
Um, I left out Chicago, Detroit, Hartford, and Hartford as well.
And then when Peter decided to go back to school, they asked me to, they asked me to, to become executive director,
and I agreed to do that. So that took me, you know, going to visit the, you know, the city projects around the country.
Um, created opportunities like, to meet people like Jim and James and Grace Boggs.
Yeah, I have a range of questions about that.
Just, just, just went back, just a bit, and I'll ask you one more thing.
Um, just interested, um, is there anything more to say about, um, your mother?
Her, her, her influence was, was, um, incalculable.
Means she, in effect, devoted her life to me.
And that's another reason I tried to do, to do well to honor her, her commitment.
You don't make me cry.
It happens lots of reasons.
Yeah.
But she was a great, great person.
I had great relatives in my house.
uncles, and great relatives.
And that's what I, you see missing with this, this generation, there's no, there's no community.
You kind of belong to the community.
And, and where I lived on Walnut Avenue, the, it was still, you know, Jewish, Irish, um, Armenians.
The, um, in the, no, I went to Henry Lee Henry Lee Higginson School School.
That's, it was from Henry Lee Henry Lee Higginson School School that I went to Latin school.
So you had all of these different nationalities in your, in your classroom, but the black community in your neighborhood, um, mostly you up, went to the same church.
But you were, you were, you belonged to everybody.
And you recognized, but for example, when a few years ago, Grace Boggs was telling me about Detroit and she was saying, Billy, we can't go out and organize the way we used to.
Because you got these gang bangers, you, you're taking your life in the hands just walking out in the street.
So the changes, the changes, uh, I mean, truthfully, the races in limbo as has never been before.
And, um, there's a confusion.
The young generation is, is a historical.
It's not, not their fault, but you don't have what we had.
I mean, we don't have black newspapers.
We don't have black radio stations.
Five corporations control the media.
So that there is a different, I don't blame the young people because you didn't, in our previous history, you didn't have to teach people what it meant to be black.
Um, there was continuity, but now we are, because most of black, most of our history, we have been a southern people.
But now we are two and three generations, we move from the south.
And now you have all this confusion about gender or identity and sexual orientation identity, where women, black women,
who identify as female gender before they do, and gay, who identify as gay before, before black.
And now you have the senses with all these different definitions.
Are you Hispanic, white, and Hispanic?
And now we have new, quote, black people here.
You have black people from Africa and from the West Indies, who don't have America's history behind them.
So, you know, I remember, you know, being in Harlem, being passed by black car drivers, well, been a typically black.
Or you, or getting off the, uh, flying to DC, and you have African, Indian, Bengals that may or may not pick you up,
because they want to take white people to the Virginia, to the suburbs.
So, there's a great confusion about race in America today, which of course the evil people take advantage of, divide it.
What, what, they used to divide you by color.
Now they divide you by gender and whatever.
Which was the church in Oxford?
My church, Charles Street AME Church (Boston).
Charles Street AME Church (Boston).
Did you, did you remember your early, don't you still feel that close time at church?
Are you spiritual or social life?
Not particularly, except in the service you, you become religious when you're being shot at.
No, I've never been.
I mean, I enjoy the church experience, but like I approach to, actually, I mean, a good, a good black preacher will just, you know,
at least start rapping, or she, but now I've heard some very good female preachers.
It's a whole different, a milieu, it's a whole different experience.
A good preacher will, you know, will, I will respond independently of whether I believe in the theology, but I'll certainly respond to a good preacher.
I'm going to mention to the, that one of the things that you felt in those years, I'm thinking now, like, 60s, you're moving back into Harvard,
but you felt, quite understandably, felt the curriculum of radiation, was an assembly of principal sort of institutional mechanism for acting on that.
Yeah, I think I think I, I think I did keep in touch with the NAACP, but I was in, in Cambridge, so I went back to Boston,
wasn't like being in Boston in high school.
I think in it's them, because you saw the situation of black people in different regions of the country, and so that was educational.
And while I was, our office was in, was adjacent to Harlem, not quite in Harlem.
On the down, and I worked with another great guy whose story needs to be told, Jesse Gray, the Harlem went straight to the leader.
And that was another question, and that introduced me to the whole question of the history of black communist.
And I, and the, how they had been, how they, when they insisted that, that raised Trump class, how that was a non-starter for the party.
And Jesse had been, was another Josh, had been in the merchant Marines.
So I got, I got that history of struggle from, you know, black, of, of, of black leftists.
And, and then Jesse taught me something about organizing, because he had an office like in East Harlem, East London, 14th East London.
And then, when people wanted to, got fed up with, being exploited by the landlords, he, and he was, you know, was known, written up in the papers.
They were called the office, and then we would go over to the, to the apartments.
And he would give them, you know, tap, tell them what they had to do, but you had to keep collecting the rent money and put it in the bank or somewhere so that when the strike was over, when they came to kick you out, you could have paid, paid the background.
But it was a very important lesson about how to organize, that the secret of organizing is, is, is convincing people to organize themselves, although they may not realize that it's what's happening at the time.
They're ready, and then you give them what needs to be done so that they organize, they organize, actually organize themselves.
So that was a very important lesson. And Jesse was, Jesse was a great spirit.
Oh, God. I guess he must, well, everybody seemed to hold back when he, I guess he was probably, because he died young.
I guess he was somewhere between 40 and 50.
And he was, if he was, much of a range, and then World War II and those 60, he was 24.
Yeah, probably mid 40s, probably mid 40s.
I wanted to ask, and this is maybe, maybe the connection, I wanted to ask, one of the very ancient things about Northern Student Movement, as you've noted in things you've written, is that after that, some early, after it's say, on touring black youths and communities, there was a more structural shift in the thinking and the critique and organizing became, can you organize and become a big focus, obviously.
And under your tenure as a director and predates, I think it's important to know, SNCC's later community work in some ways, is that your sense?
No, because SNCC influenced us. I don't, it would be difficult to draw the line of demarcation. People may have been doing community organizing.
Even under, even under Peter. But it became, after everybody began to understand the problem was much greater than, to doing kids.
SNCC was a major influence on our thinking. And then we had, in Detroit, we had,
the union folk, and we had the guys from Detroit who were organizing, and although they weren't in Northern Student Movement, per se, we were in touch with them.
So they were, they were a role model. And there was a great guy whose, whose history needs to be told, named Kenny Cockrel.
And Kenny was one of the organizers with a guy named General Baker of Black Youth in Detroit and became a lawyer.
And he was, the only person I have met, who almost could rap like Malcolm X. He was a fantastic rapper.
We became a lawyer and he had a few wonderful cases. He had a case with this black police woman who got into some altercation with a white officer in the police station garage.
And he got her off. And then there was another, another case of a black worker on the line who also had another off.
He may even have killed the coworker. And Kenny got him off as well. And then he ran the office. He was elected to the Detroit City Council.
And decided that that was duplicitous to try and convince people that that City Council could make the changes that were necessary.
So he resigned from the City Council. And then unfortunately he had a heart attack. And he died in his early 50s.
But he was, as we used to say, he was a bad motorcycle.
In a economic shift to New York in 1963 and across 64, you're obviously, as you mentioned, traveling to C and S and working.
The City's words involved. And you'll go to Mississippi as well in 64.
But I want to ask about how this relocation to New York brought you back in contact with Malcolm X and how the arguments you were hearing him present.
How you took them up and considered them in a relationship to what you were observing and through Northern Student Movement, through SNCC, through.
Well, as I mentioned in that critique, I'm in high school and we're watching Martin and Martin is saying things like, if any of the others to be spilled, let it be ours.
And we're saying, oh no, no, we said something a lot stronger than that actually.
No, no, we were not, we were not persuaded by that. But when I got to into New York, as I also say in the article Malcolm X was everywhere.
He was always having these rallies on 125th Street, so was Michaux. There were these guys, Eddie, Pork, Job, Davis.
They brought their ladders or whatever and they would be wrapping in front of the hotel Theresa. And Malcolm X would be walking.
And then I would go down to the restaurant. And as I said, I also had brought him after we had reconnected at Harvard, I brought him up to Harvard a couple of times a week.
I also mentioned, I don't know why I assumed him because he knew Leslie, but he did, he even visited me at my house when I, before I left Boston.
But he never tried to convert me. He never tried to convert me. Because I wasn't about to give up spare ribs and chasing young girls.
So I couldn't join the nation. I don't know.
Tell me about how you began to figure out through the political critique that Malcolm X's advancing.
Well, people don't appreciate, as I also wrote, yeah. Malcolm X, Malcolm X, as I wrote in the piece in the same way that Marx is the fundamental critic of capitalism.
And in the end, the fundamental critic of colonialism. To my mind, Malcolm X is the fundamental critic of American racism.
And he would be critiquing. And what people also don't appreciate is Malcolm X was as hard on black people as he was on white people.
And he would talk about, you know, you don't want to, you talk about your outnumbered, at the man since you were a career, if I 900 million Chinese, you don't say your outnumbered there.
He got you thinking about how you'd been brainwashed. And then he would say when he was critiquing Martin, he would talk about the sit-ins. And he would say, well, who sits?
You know, cripples sit. Old lady, he didn't say cripples. That's it. But disabled people sit. The old women sit. Baby sit. We don't need to sit. We need to stand up.
He had a way, as I said, also said, in a village voice piece, if you want to know what was going on in world events, or national events, all you did was walk on down to 125th Street, to tune in on the X, because he was a prodigious reader.
I think I made an automation and make it plain. But I caught him once reading William F. Buckley's William F. Buckley's National Review. And I asked, that's why Saturday Review was Norman Cousins + (his daughter) Andrea Cousins, Norman Cousins, and Norman Cousins + (his daughter) Andrea Cousins worked with Northern Student Movement. In fact, she works right down. She's a lay therapist down in Northampton.
But I asked why was he really William F. Buckley's National Review? And he said, because you never can tell where you come across a good idea.
He had a prodigious work habits and read every several papers a day, magazines, and always reading.
And I mean to answer your question, I was agreed with his critique of the movement and the duplicity of the government.
I mean, we have him in eyes on the prize, because the first rebellion in this country is in Birmingham in May of 1963, when there's an attempt to whack Martin.
They blow up, they bombed the A.G. Gaston Motel. They also bombed A.D. King, his brother's house. And it was then that the masses, the black masses of Birmingham erupted.
And Malcolm X makes this point that when Bull Connor was using fire hoses and whatever Kennedy said he couldn't intervene.
But as soon as the black people erupted, they nationalized the guard. And Malcolm X had, we have a famous scene. Well, it's famous to me.
In the eyes episode, The Time Has Come (1964-66)" where Malcolm X says, and there was no new law.
So, and then that's the snickering. You have the March on Washington, the Mad Girl ever since it just been assassinated.
And the snick workers in Georgia had been arrested.
For picketing outside the business of our recall of a juror, they invoke some 19th century law to arrest the snickers. And the FBI just stands around and takes notes but does nothing.
And then 64 after (Michael "Mickey") Schwerner, (James) Chaney, (Andrew) Goodman, they kill J. Edgar Hoover says that they can't protect civil rights workers.
They could COINTELPRO but they couldn't protect us.
And that's where with worse statement comes down a little later down the road. I mean black power doesn't drop from the sky.
And so, it was jail, a zillion damn times. People get tired. As Mrs. (Fannie Lou) Hamer's says, people get tired of being sick and tired. And relying on a government that does nothing for you and collaborates with the southern races when we were confronting.
Yeah. Let me ask you a bill to talk a little bit. Let's just spend a little bit of time talking. You teach it obviously and have taught it.
In depth, I've thought so much about this. Let's talk a little bit more about Malcolm X's critique of race in this role and function in this society.
Well, one of the things Malcolm X used to say is that history was the most rewarding of all subjects to study. And I remember being in the mosque and he was quoting from a book called Antislavery: The Crusade for Freedom in America by Dwight Lowell Dumond which is of course now out of print.
And Malcolm X was talking about the slave power. See, the history is all about how do you contextualize it?
What would you think? Well, suppose you were ET coming down from space and you were trying to understand. You read about the glories of America.
And then someone was asking about the greatest presidents and invariably in that lineup is Abraham Lincoln. So then ET asked me what president was here. And you say, if you've done your homework, he was the 16th president.
Now, what is your image of America if you are taught that of the 15 presidents before a tenuous slave owners? How does that square with the image of democracy? Or again, in relationship to the government's treaties with the Indians?
And once, well, we understand that they broke the treaties. But how many treaties did they break? They broke all 400. So where is the morality in which the society garrips itself?
And that's what Malcolm X would do. Malcolm X would just throw the history at you and make you rethink what you had been taught.
On one level, all societies like to think well of themselves. That's not unusual in itself. In fact, it's dirty. It's dirty, girl. But America is very pompous about it. And we've just seen it with Troy Anthony Davis. The whole world, the whole world, embassies all around the world.
There were protests. And I asked my students try to get them to understand how they're being brainwashed. I said, did you watch the Arab Spring? They said, you watch what's happening in Tunisia? Yes. You watch what's happening in Egypt? Yes. So let me ask you something. It's not only to establish the fact that the American media can bring you on-site coverage from the Middle East.
When's the last time you saw on-site coverage from Iraq or Afghanistan? And the answer is, or from the West Bank or Gaza or Tel Aviv. The answer is never. Never.
So you're being... I asked them also if they have a language to read for our newspapers just to see what stories are covered and how they're covered abroad and what stories are covered and not covered. And how they're covered here in America.
Because Americans are the most deceived, except for the people who want to be deceived. But it's... It's easier to maintain control over people if you take away their critical thinking.
And unfortunately, that seems to be... Mental retardation seems to be sweeping the country. And I just wrote a quick piece of my friends were calling me after they had been following these Republican debates and they call and said, what is happening in America?
How can these people be potential presidents of your country? The outside world doesn't understand what's going on. But America has lost its credibility in the world.
Well, it had lost it before under Bush. There was no place in the world. Bush could go whether or not protest against him. Also not covered by the media. When he went during his first term, when he went to London, he couldn't ride and he had to take a helicopter to Windsor Palace.
And the Lord Mayor, there were 15,000 security in a cost every citizen of London, two pounds to pay for his security. And the Lord Mayor said Bush was the most unwelcome visitor since William of Orange. And they would have preferred to give five pounds and have him not come, then spend two pounds for his security when he did come.
But none of this is unpleasantness is shared with the American people. So we live in a media cocoon which is improved increasingly disastrous.
I'm sure we'll come back to the media question when we talk about the effort to develop black studies curriculum. But let me ask you, holding that point, for now we ask you about your experience trying to help with an effort fundamentally to restructure the politics of Mississippi and through that effort.
National politics of race around the MVP because you would go down to Mississippi in 64.
Well, this is, you know, the government was trying to derail the student protests. And there were two opinions in Singapore. A lot of people were committed to sit-ins and protest.
But the government talked about the power of the vote. And so Robert Parris Moses goes down to Mississippi. And they had organized the freedom because the Mississippi politicians had claimed black people were happy and content and were interested in voting.
So they organized the freedom vote in 63,000 people voted. And that was also to acquaint them as later stocally and didn't lounge county to acquaint them with the procedures. The, in out of those procedures, they decided to form a political party and to challenge three of the white, the white congressman.
So they nominated Mrs. (Fannie Lou) Hamer's and Victoria Gray Adams and Annie Devine. And the lawyers went and gathered evidence as the extensive nature of voter suppression in Mississippi. And then that was a little counter-tomped for the movement because SNCC was working in the America.
The people working with the National Lawyers Guild and that, and they were two leftists for, of course, they got red-bated, two leftists for Allard Lowenstein and NAACP. But I worked all the time with William Kunstler and Arthur Kinoy.
So when I came back to organize, to help organize the congressional support for the challenge. And the guy who was really most instrumental who was also not gotten recognition that he had.
And he deserved was William Fitts Ryan. When the Congress can reconvene in January, it is he who put forward the resolution because Congress makes its own laws. And therefore the three white congressmen had to step aside while the resolution was being debated.
And when he raised it, then 50 or 60 other congressmen rose up to support him. And then when the vote was eventually taken, the MFTP got, if I remember correctly, 149 votes, which was not enough because you had to have a majority of the 435.
But at least temporarily, we had demonstrated just how crooked the system is.
Coming out of Atlantic City and then the January Chan-Fail January Challenge.
Did that, at that point, with those experiences of altered your basic perspective or just confirmed it?
I'm trying to, I wasn't in Atlantic City. I was somewhere else, but some, was I back in Mississippi? I wasn't in Atlantic City. No, because they had come up in the buses. You better turn this on. I think it was chasing.
We're back after a short break, just to get a drink for a moment. I was going to ask your perspective on that. Questions before we stopped. Did the MFTP experiences alter, adjust, or large-life confirm your perspective at the time?
I was thinking about that. My strongest memory, not memory. The strongest impact the MFTP did for me was not quite about politics per se.
I was sitting in Mrs. (Fannie Lou) Hamer's, and understanding that all of my education, that there were people like Mrs. (Fannie Lou) Hamer's who could see the world with a clarity that was infinitely superior to mine.
They had a wholesomeness. Is she going to make me cry again? If you weren't in touch with it, you just didn't realize that it existed.
It was different. Malcolm X was somebody that you could, there were two people in the far anywhere. Malcolm X was one of the other. My second mother, Katherine Dunham.
But it humbled you to realize that all of this book learning and whatever was secondary to a particular kind of acuity about what makes the world go around and what is important in the world, what's important in life.
So I think that's the strongest impact getting to know people. I mean, Robert Parris Moses was in Mississippi, prior I got there with Amzie Moore, and they tell me that he was taking people down the register and he got beaten up severely and went back and took off his t-shirt and washed it.
And then put it back on and went back down to the courthouse. But he said he was washing the shirt because he didn't want the blood to scare the people.
I mean, there is a heroism that defies description. So those are the things that, because Mrs. Wies just called Mississippi the state when he was going in.
And that's actually one of the reasons that I went ahead and got married because if I wanted something out of life in case I got killed, I wanted to partake of life.
I mean, she was a cool woman. She was super cool, but I had to spend a vast enough time. I just was trying. It was kind of like preparing your will.
What did you do? 60. I think it was 65.
Is something new from the Mississippi contest? No, no, no.
But you had that experience back then.
I went back to the state for a while.
I'm sorry, you went back after the...
Now after January, I went back for a while. No, I married this very attractive young woman who I met in New York. Turn it off.
February 21, 1965.
We were in an...
Innocent was having a meeting upstate New York and all of our project directors and people were there when we heard that Malcolm X had been killed.
First was unbelievable. Then you get pissed out of your mind.
But he was in it. Every once in a while, history will produce someone. And this village's voice piece I wrote on the 20th anniversary of Malcolm X's assassination.
I was saying, Martin kind of embodied the personality of the south. But Malcolm X embodied the personality of the urban north, black person.
So they didn't just kill a man, they killed the prototype.
So we came on back to the city to find out what had happened and whatever.
And then that day, well later for the funeral, I was just thinking,
now suppose where Wilkins had died, these liens of people, you know, be trying to go to his funeral.
I don't have anything against where Wilkins was just a different kind of image.
So that was an irreplaceable loss.
What were your choices in front of you at that point with Northern Student Movement and the Graduate School and all?
And how did you move forward from early 1965?
I was just thinking about that. I got married, went back to school.
I was still doing, running back in Washington, New York. I had a job at Columbia for a while with the Gismos father.
I'm trying to think of it. Oh, we did. That's what Vincent Harding called me again.
We put together this TV program called Black Heritage: A History of Afro-Americans, which is on CBS.
And many of the people whom he had, Vincent Harding and John Henrik Clarke.
In essence, it was the first representation of black studies, certainly on television.
But CBS would put it on five o'clock in the morning, TV in those days would go off at one or whatever.
They would come back with, I forgot what they used to call us to come back on at five or six.
And then the very first thing I would be Black Heritage: A History of Afro-Americans. And then years later, some students were trying to track it down.
And I don't remember whether it was CBS or whether it was later HBO.
Because HBO did the trial of James Earl Ray and then denied that they had done it.
And as I said, most of the people with the bogs and the law and the people who were involved in that Black Heritage: A History of Afro-Americans series,
Vincent Harding invited to Atlanta after Martin was assassinated. And Coretta asked him to become director of the Martin Luther King Jr. Center for Nonviolent Social Change.
I think I had a mistaken sense of when Black Heritage: A History of Afro-Americans aired.
It began airing...
I have...
Proximity?
Somewhere between...
I think 65 or 66, maybe 67.
Okay, I was thinking 67.
Yeah, somewhere. Am I even in 68?
Okay.
Somewhere in that, I think, in that three-year period.
Well, are there...
I'm sure there are many, but other...
Especially some things that you won't say about the...
The shift of context now back to graduate school and...
You know, finding your academic life now engaging these same questions, but from that angle.
Well, I had discovered another hero to study.
Frantz Fanon.
So I was...
And I gave that to you, the Algerian War of Independence (1954-62).
The...
So...
Plunging myself into the...
Into the Algerian War of Independence (1954-62).
The...
And appreciating...
Frantz Fanon.
So...
Did you discover that another hero?
Was that Frantz Fanon?
I mean, he came across...
No, well...
Frantz Fanon emerged in the movement.
Because many people who were opposed to Martin's nonviolence would quote Frantz Fanon.
Because Frantz Fanon talked about veranda colonialism" and the veranda colonialism".
So, never read like it.
They don't need that.
Never read about it.
And then they were squat about the Algerian War of Independence (1954-62).
But they would just take an exit from Frantz Fanon and use it to contravene Martin's notion of nonviolence.
So, then I decided to read the book.
And then from there I decided, you know, I went on to try and understand the whole...
You know, the whole...
Because then every other thing...
All kinds of other things open up.
You know, the...
You know, the contribution, the French Africans in World War II.
In the liberation of Paris, the Allies insisted that the Black troops not march.
They went and got anybody who did look black, Egyptians, whatever other Europeans to march, you know, down the Shaman's
allies and the Austro-Tremor.
I mean, the racism is incredible.
And...
So, that just opened up a whole different...
Broadened my perspective about what Malcolm X was talking about, how rewarding a subject of study history is.
But you begin to put things together.
Because for history is...
I tell my students, history is just...
It's not about dates.
You understand the significance of dates and events when you understand the continuity.
How things are connected.
You remember, it's not to...
But just to remember dates abstractly, doesn't mean anything to you.
What is the flow of history?
How do we get from A to B to C to D?
And once you begin to understand the flow, then things become remarkably clearer.
And even...
You may even remember them.
I have to...
The graduate faculty at Harvard responded to the work you were doing at the University of Medicine.
Well, I was...
A study with Erik H. Erikson.
And initially, I was going to be a shrink.
Because I loved Freud.
And...
And they had told me...
What was this class I was taking with?
Edwin G. Boring?
Edward Edwin G. Boring?
He was a psychologist.
Interesting guy.
But the...
We went to...
A mental hospital in Waltham.
And there was a black guy there.
And at the time, we were studying this English guy, non-directive therapy.
So when you're involved with a relationship with...
In that diatic relationship, the two of you...
You're never supposed to impose yourself.
And so, you know, the typical technique is...
When they say something, you simply repeat it.
So he asked me,
Are you one, two?
And I said, Am I one?
And it turned out he was a World War I vet.
And racism had driven him crazy.
And then the field changed.
The field went from psychoanalysis to drug therapy.
And then when I discovered phenol, I said, Well, that's the psychology.
I'm interested in it.
That liberation cycle.
Yeah, liberation therapy.
That's what I'm interested in.
So I made this switch from Freud to phenol.
In fact, years ago,
I brought a man of phenol here to speak before she died.
Actually, he's alleged to a committed suicide,
which I don't understand.
Josie Fanon.
Have you ever been to...
Algiers?
Paris?
J'aime Paris.
Let's talk about the merchants after...
Well, actually, maybe stop and...
Ask you about...
The events of spring of 1968 and how they were in their course in a year or so lead to the notion of the anti-government.
I may be, it may be a good point to talk about time.
And then how do you along view of Dr. Kim?
Well, as I said, my initial view of mind.
I met Martin a couple of times in the course of the movement.
But he didn't make any particular...
And of course, I had been in Selma when he turned us around.
Yeah, I was in Selma for the third march, because there were three.
And in fact, SCLC...
You know, the original march was supposed to be for...
to carry Jimmie Lee Jackson's body to the Capitol.
But SCLC toned it down.
And made it a voting rights march.
And so they called for us, and I came down with the innocent people.
But in fact, you would not be able to recognize it, but we were captured in one of the eyes.
In the eyes episode, Bridge to Freedom".
You see our bus pulling into Selma and innocent people.
And I getting off the bus.
But then after he turned us around, and we found out that a deal had been made,
it did not enhance my view of Martin.
It's only later in Atlanta with Benson listening, because Benson was an Albany with Martin.
And he lived across...
and also lived across the street from...
Gladys Knight went to the church across the street from Benson's house.
And Bernice Johnson Reagon lived on the first floor of Benson's house.
But when Benson started...
when we started researching, our initial project was to try and understand the movement
that had just ended.
When he started talking about Martin, and his relationship to Martin,
the things Martin had done, and the things that Martin had been subjected to.
And then later, when I started teaching on Martin and Malcolm X,
and (David J.) Garrow's Bearing the Cross,
I gained a greater admiration for Martin,
because Martin was converging toward Malcolm X.
There's a quote that I use and make it plain, that he makes six months before his assassination,
where he says that everything he has been doing so far has been in vain.
The whole thing has to be done away with.
Dabba, dabba, dabba, do.
So Martin, and that's the same disillusionment at least of Black Power.
It's the same disillusionment that most of the movement people went through.
When Malcolm X is attacked for being a hater and preaching violence,
as I said, he was hard on Black people as he was on white people.
But the critical question is not whether or not Malcolm X was a hater.
The critical question is, why did tens of thousands and thousands more of Black men and women
be sympathetic to Elijah Muhammad's description of the white man at the devil?
That's the question.
But America can't face itself.
It can't face evil in its history.
Everything it does is supposedly.
So it talks about, again, to go back to the Lincoln example.
Oh, yes, there was slavery here.
There was a little blip.
It's a little blip, unforeseen in blip in our history.
But in 1860, America was the greatest slavehold in country and the history of the world.
So when you start recontextualizing things, you draw much different conclusions.
So I began to, after his death, and principally through Benson,
until he researched, we did an IVW and subsequent research from my Malcolm X,
and Martin, of course, I began to gain much more respect from Martin.
If you just look here, one of the things that he and Malcolm X had in common,
they were always on the road.
And Martin had this whole responsibility to raise money for SCLC.
And then the jealousy that he had to contain with.
I began to appreciate it much more as a very, very significant distinguished, important person.
Come up with some heart.
Benson.
I met Benson, who had, I think, my amulet while, for some kind of mini-conference,
where we were on a panel together with First Man.
And then we stayed in touch.
When Black Heritage: A History of Afro-Americans came up here, John Clark asked me to participate in that.
I'm sorry, when did you?
John Henrik Clarke and Benson.
So I participated in that.
And then when he told me about the IVW and asked me to come join him in Atlanta,
I said yes.
Because the movement, the formal movement, had died.
And there were all of these, you had all of these different things were going on.
You had Pan-Africanism.
Amiri Baraka.
And everybody was changing their name, which I thought was ridiculous.
Back as a very interesting debate between me and Stokeley on this whole question of.
And that is all African people's revolutionary part.
I said, All-African People's Revolutionary Party.
This is our struggle here.
And go organize your mama.
You have to mobilize people into Inspire.
You must talk to them as Mao Zedong.
And as I'm paraphrasing, in the language they understand.
So I had been there.
It was a concert in Howard to which Walter Rodney came.
And we had, and Robert Hill, who is the Garvey Scarlett, UCLA.
And Walter, they had been at Monatica, (University of) Mona, Jamaica.
And then they had gone, they had been together in 68 at a black-rightest conference, I think, in Toronto.
And then the Jamaican government, the JLP, did not allow Walter to return.
So Walter was, went to Tanzania, was teaching at the University of Dar es Salaam.
But probably something before that, because he may have been in Guyana at some point.
Because anyway, he came up, he came up, yeah, 71 or 72.
He came back.
He had gone, he had gotten the job to teach at the In Guyana, but they wouldn't,
what for Walter Brennan wouldn't let him.
So what we, Emmanuel Wallerstein, and James Turner.
And I had, yeah, this was later than.
We would get speaking engagements for him to help him raise money.
But Walter came to the, before that, Walter had come to some research symposium that we conducted at Atlanta.
And we became great friends. So I went to Africa in 71 or 72 to visit him in University of Dar es Salaam.
And that was also another eye-opening experience, because you had, you know,
(Julius) Nyerere was being, like in (Kwame) Nkrumah, had been previously, was being idolized in the Black world.
And you, just like these American black expats were going to Guyana,
you had these black expats living in Tanzania.
And I just found them very funny, actually, because they were living in this country,
but they hadn't learned the language.
And then when I got off the plane and ran into them,
and I just thought it was very revealing the question they asked me,
how are the Green Bay Packers doing.
I've captured it, which was another important lesson that I learned,
which was reinforced when I, F, I went to Cuba.
You may rail against this country.
You may call it all kinds of names, but you have no idea how it is crept into your mind.
What are you used to? You go in, it's dark in a room, and you turn on the lights.
Well, what happens when you're somewhere where there is no electricity?
Or you're going to take a shower, and you must, in your shower, and water being pumped from the sea.
Or there are no, I was going to visit my grandparents in Georgia.
I was used to outhouses.
So that wasn't, that wasn't.
But still, you gain more appreciation of the extent to which you may have disagreements
with a particular society, but how it has affected you in ways that are beyond your kin.
And then you have to come to terms with, then you have to come to terms with the degree to which you have been socialized by the forces that you are railing against.
So that was an important lesson for me in, in dark.
Tell me about the, tell me about the mood and the project of IBW.
It was, it's an ambitious mission statement that emerges.
Well, it was the black studies thing.
So we had a major conference, we brought in the people who were initiating black studies.
As I should have mentioned in terms of the MFDP, the person who was organizing out of Washington was Ekwueme Michael Thelwell, who was here just retired from here.
The way would Jamaica.
But initially, as I said, it was, well, there was a little tension because the advisors of the King's Center wanted it to simply be, you know, Hallelujah Martin.
And they almost wanted us to take up an oath of, of nonviolence.
And we said, no, later, maybe we ain't doing that.
So, so then we split and became, and became, and became independent.
And we had newsletters and we were commenting on, on current events.
We had students that we were teaching, some of whom we've been kicked out of protesting out of more house and elsewhere.
And we had a relationship with Wesley. And so we had students from Wesley who came down to us, to us, some post, some of research, who came down to study with us.
In fact, you're working with one, James Early. Early was one of my students who might just have their own subsequently.
No, that's not true. We stay. He calls me Papa.
And we've also had a mutual tie to the Cuban.
Yeah.
But then we just, you know, we got, I'm sure the office was broken into several times. I'm sure we were co-in-tell-prod.
And then of course, the powers that be, after we separated from, as I said in the piece after we lost Martin, Vincent [Harding knew it] was much more difficult to get foundation money".
So we had to decide the triumphant is independent as we could.
So then some of us who had degrees, Vincent Harding left, went to his quick, Vincent Harding's a midnight.
I guess that's one of the ties between, religion is a tie between him and Martin.
So he went to Pendle Hill, Chester Davis, who had taught at Sir George Napper Williams in Canada, who was our education person.
He came here and here at the time at New Mass, Towa was here, who my new from SNCC, and Ivan Hall, who my new from SNCC.
And there was a guy whom I didn't know, Sherry Gelaal, who was with the Algerian War of Independence (1954-62). And he used to teach the Fanon course.
So Ivan Hall and Gelaal, I hope I'm pronouncing his name, when they left, they asked me to come and take their places.
And so that was, that's what I did. And in those days it was, it was no big thing, because you could fly from New York to Atlanta for 90 bucks.
So we all computed back and, I say, computed, commuted back and forth for many years.
And then Howard Dodson, who had been in one of our, had come in with Andrew Billingsley and from California.
And George Napper, George Napper became police commissioner of Atlanta.
But he had been a student of Billingsley's. How would then, how would then became director by BW.
And then after Howard we had to, Jan Douglass and Pat Daly essentially who ran, I BW. So I BW lasted till 1983.
Well, we started today with a new book about BW by Derrick E. White. And in a piece that he did last year.
But as I'm saying in a book yet, then the piece that he wrote a year ago, kind of on that BW, turned left in my country, his study is in.
He said that he described you in kind of the tally of faculty and staff who emerged early on BW.
That you were a, the staff of Malcolm X the Black and a political nationalist in that context.
And I'm wondering if that is the way that you would have made the description and whatever your answer to that is,
how you would have described your, your kind of philosophy and perspective.
Well, I never thought about how to describe myself politically actually.
I think Manning Marable wrote a piece once in which he described James Turner and me as left nationalist.
But if I were to pick one, I would say, you know, if I'm anything, I'm a Malcolm X, and Malcolm X is the fundamental guiding political influence of BW.
And in my life, yeah.
I have this, I just, I just said I just got Derrick E. White. I have to see how he, you know, tells the story.
Although I read his dissertation and when I read it seemed to me of the treatment so far, I think he's done the best job.
And it's hard to describe. I mean, I read W was the first and the only independent Black thing tank in this country's history.
And trying to, I mean, there's a, one of the most important elements of struggle is who defines.
I mean, there's an African fable that tells me that the one day, the little elephant comes home from school and asks his mother.
He says, mother, in school, the lion said, they had the king of the jungle. And I thought, we were the king of the jungle.
And this mother tells him, well, there will always tease that in your school until we run the school.
So there's a dialectic there. And the history, the Negro history begins first trying to excavate, you know, Black people's contributions to the land to try and advance the case.
Please treat us as equals.
But then Black studies comes along. When you begin to dig up the suppressed lacuna, you begin to get a whole different history of America.
And then you begin to get when people talk about Malcolm X as a critique.
In my judgment, you have to put Malcolm X with Jimmy Baldwin.
Because the firing next time Jimmy lays America down on the couch and analyzes it.
And he analyzes the psychology of racism. The Black people, you know, he says, if it's supposed to be on a bucket and when Black people are the bucket, and then America stands on this bucket.
When you pull the bucket off of Monday the Feet, they go topsy-turvy. So you must keep this hierarchy as fundamental to the maintenance of America's identity.
So Jimmy must, in my judgment, you know, along with Malcolm X is the two sharpest critics of the contradictions of American society in their time period.
Did you hear any moves from him?
We've certainly touched on that then, all right now. But I still feel in some way that we haven't quite done what we might.
It would be very valuable in this series to have you say a little bit more about the full nature of the critique as you were hinting.
And I'm hinting when we get, you know, describing it in some reform. Are there more things that you would like to say?
Well, what you understood, to go back to your earlier point, Vincent Harding was a tremendous influence.
Vincent Harding does, he does, there is a river that history up to the Civil War, there is, given his, there is a river, the streams of which make glad the people of God.
And then we were, we thought we had a contract with a WETA-TV-TV, to do something like Black Heritage: A History of Afro-Americans.
And so we put together a history because it was supposed to be yes, it was supposed to be for the Centennial in 1976, I think.
But then the station got barred, us anyway. Oh no, roots came. And they said, well, one Black thing is enough. So they did so, roots took our, was the Black historical television story for the year.
So Vincent Harding took what we had done and he published it as the other American Revolution. And then later he's done a book, he's done hope in history, how to teach the history of the movement, you know, to high school young people.
And then Vincent Harding, Martin Luther King: The Inconvenient Hero because as I again tell the students, what do you all they know about Martin is the March on Washington and I have a dream.
But the next five years of Martin's life, but not all world's memory hole. And that's what Vincent Harding, Vincent Harding explains the whole history of Martin.
And especially those last five years, Martin's development and his evolution. So Vincent Harding was a tremendous influence on me at least. And I think on everybody, as I, he and the Rome helped me think about how to write better.
And as I also said, he has the gift of communication. As I said earlier, you know, your mother could be dead. But by the time Vincent Harding explained to you, he'd be, oh, my God.
The Malif Lewis one I call it. He just turned 80.
But he's still out here. He and Grace Boggs was 95 going around the country trying to form alliances between seniors and young people. the oral history project at Iliff he's been directing for the last decade, decade, decade and a half probably.
We haven't done it but public insted, but if you're interested, have you, uh, reflect a little bit about, um, come help or all that, the whole better, by the state to smash domestic and same.
Well, we always said the man was everywhere. Um, but we know we thought FBI CIA, we didn't know after Malcolm X found out the MI5 and the Seret, the most side, and everybody was tracking Malcolm X.
And, um, and Martin to the state department, the, you know, Malcolm X seemed too much of a danger to too many, too many people.
So you always assume, I mean, your experience was you've seen the FBI doing nothing and virtually colluding with the forces of you.
Um, so you had no respect for them. And then you have the other question, not just commentel, but you have the question of the behavior of, of the, of the police.
The police are the, are the military arm of the racist state. And every rebellion, we'll ask, when we begin talking about 63, every rebellion in this country with the exception of May 63 in Birmingham,
uh, and the, and the zillion that occurred, I think 200 after Martin's assassination, every rebellion, not a race right, every rebellion was in response to some police act of racism, either actual or, or, or perceived, people thought they've done something.
And so they blow up.
So you had, and that's why this whole history of urban rebellion, because race rides, it, it, it has the connotation like of two forces and, and also mindlessness, you know, rioting.
There's no reason, there's no political reason, there's no justification, but they people just rioting. But, but I have been in, I was in Harlem in 64 when I was in Detroit in 67.
And the rebellion's in six in Detroit were quite purposeful. The Lebanese who called themselves Chaldeans, who were exploiting the, they purposely, um, there still was, were targeted.
And not only were they targeted, requests were made. People with, whether they want a TV, want it, percent.
They would provide people, people put in the order. They would get, they would, they would get whatever the merchandise was. And then after they had satisfied all of the, all of the community demands, then they would, then they would, you know, crack, crack this, crack this story.
But I also was, the, the, the new black power conference, which was held after, after Newark, will once again, the residents were,
were targeted particular stores. But then the National Guard came in and perceived what was going on. And so they smashed everything to convey this notion of mindlessness.
And the same thing in Detroit, the media would report, why are they burning down their homes? And when people are not burning down their homes, it's because the wind, the fire department would not, would not come down into the areas of the wind, blooded am flames over there.
And this, this necessity, because if rebellion is legitimate, then America is illegitimate. And so therefore you must always define the behavior as illegitimate.
So those are the kind of things that, that IBW and looking at what was going on, how America interprets events, that crystallize your, your concept of, of an analysis of the nation.
As they say, we're back, we're back on that track.
Sit down more.
Let me ask about the project that culminated I think 94 with publication and make it plan the book on Malcolm X.
I'm interested in your reflections on that of course, those are, those are, companion to a, to a documentary that was televised.
And I'm interested in your perspective on interpreting Malcolm X that kind of context for all the, the national popular audience and so on.
Well, make it planarized out of, and eyes on the prize episode, the episodes called The Time Has Come (1964-66)". It was a half hour, was one, and then it goes on to the, to the Meredith March Against Fear, Meredith March.
But, um, Blackside, Henry Hampton's organization, who must be given great, because he got, this, this, eyes on the prize funded during the Reagan era.
The, um, that episode got more response than any other episode in the I series.
And so Blackside would then enter into a, a relationship with PBS to do, to do make it, to do make it plan.
And they, since I had been a consultant for the eyes episode, they asked me to consult on the, in an, in essence, to be in Monis, they asked me to be chief consultant.
And so I did, I agreed to do that. And then they asked, they wanted a companion book, and they asked, a much more well-known writer than I, um, to, and he presented a proposal and I saw it, and thought it was lacking.
And so I critiqued it, and suggested how the, the book, the introduction of the book should go. And they said, well, write it.
And I said, okay. Because at the time, there was this great, hover balloon around Malcolm X, the route people, public, and it was taught.
And the autobiography was in every, in every bookstore. And I thought that people really didn't appreciate.
I wanted to try and describe what, as objectively as I could, why I thought Malcolm X was a great man. And that's how I tried to write, to write, make it plan.
What was that on the, like, the falls were, we'll go back after a short break.
We'll take just a minute here, and since we've just talked about, make a plan, and you obviously are right now, I've just published a piece on intersponsored to the new many Marable, Malcolm X X, biography.
Can you summarize the critique of Marable's book that you presented there?
Well, essentially, the critique is that the book is full of historical omissions and historical gaps, and unverified speculation.
And on the re-invention trope.
Well, re-invention places the agency in the hands of the interpreter. And what I attempted to show in the article is that that methodology could be applied to anyone, and could be applied nefariously if one was so inclined.
But the, the, the, the trashing of everyone that Manning does, Betty Shabazz, and Alex Haley in addition to Malcolm X, and the self-registness with which he puts himself forward as someone now who is going to, to give the world a real story.
And there is, in fact, hardly nothing that's really new. The, the Malcolm X assassins. In fact, earlier, when Talmadge Hayer with William Kunstler had, was fighting for a new trial, he identified the other four people.
And that information was written, published in Karl Evanzz, and was also published. And most of it was published in Karl Evanzz's book, the Judas Factor, who killed Malcolm X X.
And there's lots of attribution. There are lots of borrowings from other people in Manning's book that are not attributed. He borrows heavily from Evans. Evans' book on the messenger, Evans' book on, he borrows heavily from Make It Plane.
No. It is truly unfortunate he is not here to explain himself.
Let me shift back to something that we wanted to cover and, let's get to over the not-small question of the SDS.
Yeah, I had, the SDS had been a very good relations with the original Northern Student Movement. And I met them. We had a joint conference at Ann Arbor, at some point, and 60.
I think later, 63. And then SDS went into community organizing as well. Junius Williams was in Newark. And we said, what do you guys want me to try and copy my shit?
And then they did ERAP to them. They tried Stanley Aronowitz, it was one of the major ideologues. They were trying to organize on an economic basis. And then they were trying to do community organizing, the most famous of which was in Newark.
But we came to a little parting of the ways, because the first racial division of labor in the movement, as far as I can tell, was what we did in Northern Student Movement, years before, snake.
In fact, there's a famous, not famous, it was famous to me, when SDS people in, and Kotlin of snake were telling me that what Northern Student Movement had done was not appropriate, because we were all supposed to be one big happy family.
But what I had discovered going up to Harlem one day, one evening, that the white girls were there with the dudes, and they were sitting down on these mattresses in the basement, like an H1N57 street.
And they were drinking wine and singing Wobbly songs. And then they would take them down to Peter Butterwood's house. You look up Butterwood's house. He was a major force in terms of American involvement in Vietnam, he also was a zillionaire. But they were exposing them to a life they could never have.
And then you couldn't do anything with them after. So what we did in Northern Student Movement remained interracial. I just said no more white girls organizing in the ghetto.
So we still had white males working Frank Joyce's was the director of the Detroit Project, Sam Lakin, and folks work with me and others, there was still interracial presence in Northern Student Movement. I just said no more white girls in the ghetto. And that was in 64.
And then Snake had a ladder. It's a problem about consciousness. Why do white people come to join the struggle?
And what's their idea of struggle? The many of them remain American nationalists at heart. And they want to end poverty. They want to end the symptoms.
And then some, for example, when I was in Mississippi, we were going to register, take people to register the vote.
And this white girl wanted to hold my hand as a demonstration of, you know, we will shut overcome or togetherness or we're going to over and defeat these crackets. I said, I can't tell you what I said.
But what I ended up saying, are you crazy? Because white people don't understand what other white people capable of.
So she's going to hold my hand as a symbol of, we're going to defeat these people. Not realize she's going to get us both killed.
So it's that, how do you become acquainted with the J. Edgar Hoover and the clan of the world?
So they just have no idea about what this country, what some Americans are capable of. And it's a just, so I just said no more white girls in the ghetto.
In fact, I wrote it's in Charles E. Cobb Jr's book. Because I've been pillory racist dog. And whatever. I said no, no. This was the reality of, you know, let us suppose, what was this whole notion of, we must love one another.
And I said, it's the Cold War and we are facing potential, the destruction of humankind and we are against nuclear weapons. So we are marching against the bomb.
Are you asking the person who is marching with you against the bomb to love you? It's necessary. Why must they love you? Why must you appreciate, why must we just be not a kiss your foot because you come to help us in our struggle?
So you had to separate the wheat from the chaff in terms of white supporters who was real, who made people who made, it meant well. But they didn't or as, as a (James) Bevel — but the Pass-1-quoted "bevel one said" is likely SNCC member James Bevel said, we had high hopes, but we didn't know what we were up against.
Pardon me that point too, I guess. No, Ben says I'm in a lab, he loves everybody.
Let me ask a final thought for mine. How did you read the Obama election?
I thought it was a potential turning point for America. I didn't get ecstatic about it because the same percentage of white people who voted for McCain had voted for Bush in 2004.
The only reason Obama won is black people turned out in Virginia and Florida, North Carolina, 98% so he can win the electoral vote.
But it did appear, friends of mine in Spain and in Europe, everybody thought this because remember, he appeared to be the quintessential anti-Bush and the World Hated Bush.
Donald Duck maybe could have won. It seemed like maybe it was, and then what he, in his campaign, the things he was saying, it looked like the possibility of real change.
We bring back to final thought and the construction of culture and the construction of what passes history and consciousness and all.
Just interested a little bit and if you talk a little bit about your perspective on what you work hard as really well considered by studies curriculum.
Well, it's what I think now is not what I thought, not what I thought before precisely because of the changes that have occurred.
Black studies per se to paraphrase, stokely, is necessary but it is no longer sufficient.
We are all on a ship called America and if the ship goes down whether we are first class working with the captain or in stereo, we all go down together and America is going on its way to hell.
We are the greatest detonation in the history of the world. The people who are supposed to Obama at all, who are supposed to confront the problem, cannot confront the problem because they only admit what the real problem is.
You paid more taxes than General Electric in Bank of America. Corporations pay 6.6% of the federal budget.
The masses out of income tax and payroll taxes contribute 84%. And now they are laying off the public sector so the revenues will decrease.
We have a $15 trillion debt. We pay a trillion dollars, an interest on the debt which is never discussed.
So what do they do with all this discussion yesterday and today about Geithner and the G20?
All the fed is like a monopoly game. Print money, print money, print money, print money but it cannot last.
And so what do you, the people who understand that it cannot last? What happens when the dollar is no longer the international reserve currency?
What happens? If this cannot last unless and the jobs are not coming back, the three million jobs are not coming back when you subsidize corporations to export jobs.
The system is so corrupt. You have (likely) ALEC and politicians. They've written 800 laws.
There's nobody in Congress writing laws for the public interest.
And so when you ask about black studies, we are now in a different era because America was built upon the exploitation of the confiscation of Indian land and the exploitation of black labor until the industrial society.
So immigrants, white immigrants could come and they could get these jobs. But now they exploit new tools.
So I mean this is the problem. There's no real discussion of the real problems and therefore there's no real solutions being put forward.
Just print more money or because the same people have the same perspective globally as here in America. The only solution they have is so-called austerity.
That means screw the public sector with that cannot work. So we have white family income. Black people are disposable. We are now irrelevant.
And increasingly large in numbers of white people are now economically irrelevant. And they don't care about education. The Reagan came to office. They wanted to get rid of the Department of Education.
All they care about is privatizing education as they privatize prisons as they want to privatize social security as they want to privatize every bush privatize 25% of the IRS which people don't know.
So I had a grad student and they audited her. She made $22,000. They audited her. They know audit but as Buffett said they know audit. And they didn't audit. We now find out the SEC destroyed 9,000 documents of investigation.
We now find out that the General Counsel of the SEC had $2 million invested in it made off. Corruption with a capital K.
So how do we and what have they done? We ask about Obama. Obama is irrelevant because they have infiltrated all of the ABC. The Foxes are in the Hen House, in the SEC, in the NLRB, in the FAA.
You flew here in a plane 35 years old, monitored by air traffic control system also 35 years old. And they privatized the subcontractors to take care of the planes.
Now, everywhere you look there is corruption and money over ours. But these people are different historically because one can make a case that slavery is logical.
One can make a case that feudalism is logical. But these forces, they have let loose forces that they cannot control and they don't care about the ozone depletion.
So and you have a clown like (Texas Governor) Rick Perry who doesn't believe in climate change while 78% of his state is on fire and the drought and cows are dying.
These people are mad. We are in the hands of idiots and maniacs and racist corruption. And I ask, I do not understand why there is not a revolution in this country.
But there is no opposition that will explain to people what are the problems and what must be done. That's why as I say about black people, just because our cars is just like the Indians does not mean we will triumph.
And America is going steadily. People all around the world, America's lost its credibility. We are on the wrong side of every question.
It's unbelievable. But the American people, what are the watching reality television and Fox News and Shrek too?
It's Shrek. It's a Shrek fire, no. Right.
We are back on it and during the quick break, Bill wanted to ask you just to stretch out and say a little bit more about the rationale and the argument that led you to move white women out of the project of urban organizing.
Well, the singing of the wobbly songs, that was their legacy. That was their notion of politics. But you cannot, but you don't drink wine with people whom you are organizing.
It's just like you don't have sexual relations with people whom you are organizing. Although there were some people who believed that you had makeup with everybody.
I agree with them as well. It's good looking when we saw you across the, not in our thing, but a SNCC person, a SCLC person who was James Bevel.
Who's predilections of, you know, who expose at the end of his life, terrible revelations about Bevel.
So, and taking them down to the east side, then you have to go back to Harlem.
Down to the people who were organizing back to the Harlem songies.
Down to the people who were like, go look up after this, who peed a button with the ones. They are exposing them to something that has nothing to do with struggle.
Well, that's kind of where the song was born. The radical chic where the white campus would take into all the east side parties.
You can raise funds for these, you know, that's a similar kind of pension.
Well, I had a problem with the panthers.
Because actually it was the white left in the European left that is lionized, lionized the panthers.
Which is not to say some of them. But I have guys who, because as we said before about the relationship between the black community and the police,
to confront the police, to try and organize against the police is quite logical and was important.
But they got friends of mine who in the Jersey City BPP, they got killed, cops just like they killed Fred Hampton and Mark Clark.
So that if you're going to speak as an ex-marine, if you're going to take on the enemy, understand what you're doing.
You don't announce, hello, I'm going to be out at 430 right now, that we're creating and we're going to get you or we're going to pretend to get you.
So people don't understand what a real confrontation with the police would entail.
As I said, I was in the, if I had had my platoon in Detroit, we could have taken over the city.
Because the cops were shooting each other. They didn't know what they were doing.
We could have taken over the city, we couldn't have held it, but we could have taken it for a day, for a day and a half.
But the, just like, there is no theory of change in America because America is the best of all possible worlds.
All we have are blips that we can correct a little blip here, a little bit there.
But there's no concept that the whole, as Martin said, that the whole thing must be done away with.
So we have yet to have, when people may talk about Marxism, we talk about this and that.
But we've yet to develop, and that's something that Malcolm X was working on.
Something that the Boggses was laying out. But Malcolm X was working on, how do you really affect change in this country?
He put forward, as I wrote it, and he put forward two things, internationally and internationally.
Valorant of the bullet was the national strategy, but hooking up with the, and exposing to the UN and elsewhere, hooking up with, was the international struggles.
He was invited, he was invited to Algeria in March of 65.
He's been a he and Che, been well-invited them both to a conference in Algeria.
So he was conveniently killed two weeks, two and a half weeks before leaving for Algeria.
Bill Spina, it's been a real privilege and a long, and thank you for such a thoughtful and extensive commitment.
Are there any final thoughts, sir?
Nothing with a thousand things later.
People I left to help, people I should have mentioned.
I don't know, thank you.
But people have been asking me to do a memoir on, and one of the things that I've been lucky enough to meet some great, great people,
and being able to explain, from my limited viewpoint, the significance of those people that I try to do with Malcolm X, is what make me sit down and write this memoir, called Once Upon a Time.
Thank you.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.